Kip wrote in tip says hey David it seems
like warfare is really changing between
drones cyber war sanctions and other
tools will we ever have a major world
war yet again very interesting question
I think that we are clearly going away
from the idea of these major world wars
being possible for a few reasons now I'm
against nuclear proliferation I am
against it but it is true that if it is
known that a country has nuclear weapons
it does serve as somewhat of a deterrent
to a country that does not have them
from getting involved militarily in some
kind of major war sort of scenario
although I I don't I I think that there
are way more reasons to D proliferate
from nuclear weapons than to have them
as a deterrent globalization is a major
factor right when you look at trade
right now and you look at the sort of
supply chain there are fewer and fewer
parts of the world that are sort of
disconnected from impacting major
Western powers which it's just sort of
the reality that's a big factor in terms
of how warfare like the old days is or
isn't going to be done so I think that
globalization and trade deals are a big
part of why we wouldn't see that and I
also think that cyber warfare and drones
are a really really big factor because
you can do much more damage relative to
the risk that you expose yourself to
through technological means like drone
warfare as well as cyber warfare so I do
believe that we are moving away from the
sort of major world war and Wars of the
style of world wars 1 & 2 and the
Vietnam War well just starting with a
nuclear weapons point I mean since the
50s we've had the concept of mutually
assured destruction yep I think that
assumes that we have rational actors in
our roles of leadership yes and when you
look at like donald trump kim jong hyun
joong geun i mean you can't just make
that assertion necessarily I think that
sometimes we understate the rationality
of kim jong hoon and believe me i am a
major critic of kim jong hoon but I
guess what I'm talking about is the
North Korean regime at large we are now
in the third Jenner
of this wacky megalomaniac family
running North Korea and they still do
seem to have limits as to what they do
they will bluster they will do missile
tests and make incredible threats but
they haven't actually gone further and I
know that a lot of people will say well
they've not yet developed the mega nuke
that they could drop on New York City
but I'm not talking about that they've
not gone even nearly as far as their
current technology would allow them to
so while I believe that Kim jong-un and
that regime is incredibly erratic I do
think Pat that some people overstate the
errata sysm of the North Korean regime
when it comes to starving their own
people
there is no overstating it but when it
comes to at any point they'll launch a
nuke against the US it's we're on
generation three right now right I mean
if they may just be waiting to a point
where they can attach a nuclear weapons
whoo warhead lying in well until that
team on the west coast maybe I don't
know do you really but do you think
there's something to it though that they
do seem to have some limits to what they
know would just create it would be a
suicide action it's mostly bluster I
mean how can we say for sure but even if
there's a 5% chance that's still very
very concerned yeah it's a 1 out of 20
chance and they've made more than 20
threats so far ok so very good question
I do believe we are moving away from
this paradigm of the sort of major world
war as we saw during the 20th century